やあみんなドーゲンここで
かなり疲れているように見えたらごめんなさい
地震
と余震が続いているのであまり眠れ
ませんでしたので月曜日に私が持っていない地震のためにビデオをリリースすることができません
まったく眠れなかった
ので、コンピューターを壁から外しましたが、
この機会に
地震について話し
、友人や家族を更新し、そこで
何が起こっているのかについて話したいと思い
ました。
数日前の熊本での
非常に大きな地震で、私が住んでいる場所に非常に近く、
建物が倒れるほどの大きさで、数
人の
死者が出ました。 二度目の
地震が来て、私が住んでいた最初の地震
はそれを感じましたが、それが山の上の私の場所であったかどうかはわかりませんが、
それほど大きくはあり
ませんでした。 これを
見たことがありますが、揺れています w
今、また余震が起こっていますが、
それは最初の地震では
感じませんでしたが
、私が住んでいた場所ではそれほど不快ではなかったので、日本
に住む前と同じような大きな地震を感じました。
私の出身地であるシアトルに戻ったのですが、昨夜の
真夜中頃
に私が住んでいる場所で非常に大きな地震が発生
しました。 日本の
スキルですが、それは非常に大きく
、壁に取り付けられたモニターを見ると、アパートの多くのものが落ちました。私が
すべてを降ろした場所に非常に傾いていました。
カメラと三脚
とマイクあそこのマイクは
、いくつかの重りなどに取り付けられていることを知っていると感じましたが
、椅子から落ちました。
準備ができているかどうかはわかりませんが、すべて
の皿が落ちたと言ったの
ですが、 あちこちに
落ちて大きかったe アパート
から出て外に出なければならないかもしれないと感じるのは難しいです
が、どうし
たらいいか考えていたとき
に、一瞬止まってしまい、大きなものは終わりました。
私が理解していることから
、これらの余震の多くで感じるのに十分な大きさの200以上の余震は、
これまでに経験したどの地震よりも大きい
ので、かなり参加してい
ます。 満期か
申し訳ありませんが、私はかなり疲れています。昨夜はあまり眠れませんでした。
なぜなら
、私たちが眠ろうとするたびに、別の巨大な
余震が来るだけ
で、ベッドから戻って私たちを揺さぶるのを知っているから
です。
昨夜の午前2時か3時頃の台所のテーブルの下での時間
私と私の妻は両方とも
完全に安全ですが、それは非常に
奇妙に感じます私は戦争地帯に行ったことがありませんが
余震が絶え間なく飛んでいるようなものです
地震についての私たちの携帯電話
の警告がちょうど止まることなく消えているのはいつもサイレンが鳴っていますそしてそれ
はあなたたちが見たということです私
は数秒前に起こった余震が起こった
ので作ることができないと思います ビデオです
が、友人や
家族に何が起こっているのかを知らせたかったのですが、
職場でも少しの
被害があり、
友人や同僚に
も大きな被害を受けた場所がたくさんあり
ます。 私たちのアパート自体は
構造的には素晴らしいように見えますが、私が言った
ように私が知っている人々の多くは
彼らのアパートに大きな亀裂があり、
彼らは実際に避難しなければならなかったので
、私の妻がカメラに映りたくないので申し訳ありませ
ん それが
日本で
起こっていることです。最悪の事態は終わり
、余震の頻度とサイズは
過去14時間ほどで徐々に減少しているようです
が、それは非常に
衝撃的ですが、  h私は大丈夫です私は
完全に肉体的に元気です
私の妻は完全に肉体的に元気です
そして私が接触したすべて
の人はこの状況で非常に怖がっている多くの人々がいました
があなたです
多くの場所が
私たちが住んでいることを知っているか、ここよりずっと年上であるということを知っているので、非常に理解しやすい
です。 みんな更新しました
他に何かあったらお知らせしますので
、九州の熊本の日本へのサポートに感謝し
ます。